does anyone else find it interesting
that the authorities within Egypt are
hoping that the newly found necropolis
of underground mummies will increase the
tourism within the country ever since it
plummeted in the last several years
following Wars and all kinds of
political turmoil I mean you may
remember the stories that made
international headlines around the world
about two hidden chambers within the
Great Pyramid of Giza that were
allegedly to be excavated and here we
are more than a year and a half later
and they haven't even looked into it at
all allegedly wait a second why would I
say allegedly I'll get into that in a
second first let me just share with you
about these mummies and this will only
take a second because it's really not
that interesting so in the deserts of
Egypt we have found at least 17 mummies
underground approximately seven meters
down and there's at least 17 possibly 30
and for some reason they claim that
they're 2,300 years old even though
they've done no testing whatsoever
there's no evidence I mean they didn't
provide any type of scientific evidence
to back up that claim of being 2,300
years old now why would I find that
interesting well they've made up stories
about timetables before haven't they I
mean look at the case of the Great
Sphinx if you're not aware more than 200
professional geologists from numerous
countries around the world have visited
the Great Sphinx and has stated that the
evidence is overwhelmingly conclusive
that there is tens of thousands of years
of water erosion on the limestone
bedrock that encloses the things that's
interesting because Egyptologists are
adamant that the true age of the Sphinx
is only a few thousand years old between
three and four thousand years old in
fact when the last time the Nile Delta
received enough substantial rainfall to
cause this type of water erosion around
the limestone bedrock was more than
seven thousand years ago which is more
than double the age of the Sphinx I mean
never mind that the Pharaohs literally
etched in stone detailed lineage of the
Pharaohs dating back more than thirty
thousand years which Egyptologists say
is is incorrect and obviously they were
wrong and it's symbolism of something
else
okay now getting back real quick to the
two hidden chambers and how I mentioned
that allegedly they hadn't looked into
it
keep in mind that back between 1993 and
2002 there was an incident where they
went looking through a tunnel shaft
system within the Great Pyramid to look
behind a hidden doorway and even though
the Egyptian government adamantly
claimed that nobody had excavated this
site in the years between it doesn't
seem to explain the fact that there's a
broken and missing bronze handle that
was on that stone in 1993 now keep in
mind they state that the Egyptian
military guards the entire site 24/7
guys this be realistic the Egyptian
authorities have gone in there silently
secretly I mean they could do it at
night and nobody would ever know
otherwise right why else would they be
so shady about this stuff I mean the
last ancient wonder of the world that is
shrouded in so much mystery they have
evidence that there's two hidden
chambers in a year and a half later they
haven't even gone looking into it how
stupid is that I mean what what is that
don't just blame corruption in a slow
paperwork process in Egypt no no no no
they are lying to us you know this
reminds me there's been many compelling
arguments brought forward by many people
suggesting that there are two
subterranean chambers below the Great
Sphinx yet the Egyptian government
refuses to go looking into it I mean
really they can't just drill a hole and
take a peek it's funny how they get so
apprehensive about that and the true age
of the Sphinx why is that and this not
forget just how likely these two
underground chambers really are I mean
if you're not aware there is a massive
underground tunnel system within the
Giza Plateau in fact there are numerous
shafts carved into solid limestone
bedrock many of which are completely
symmetrical and plummet more than a
hundred feet down and they're completely
unexplainable nobody knows what these
shafts were used for and some of these
are actually pretty close to the Great
Sphinx as you can see there in the
background by the way you can see
pictures of Brien Foerster in these
photos and he took these photos so be
sure to check out Brian foresters
YouTube page and his website Hannah Dean
Catorce comm so to bring all this
together
what am I suggesting here I'm not
suggesting that nobody goes to visit
Egypt in fact it would be great if the
tourism increased because more people
need to go to these sites and see that
holy crap what we were taught in school
about ancient Egypt and human
civilization is so full of holes
and it's not until you actually look at
what Egypt has to offer aside from just
pictures of the pyramids then you start
to understand that there was some sort
of law thing to high technology and that
ancient humans were far more advanced
than we ever realized and date back far
earlier than what we were taught in
school
anyways I'll leave it at that I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight like and
subscribe I have many other videos to
come and a whole wide variety of topics
take care everybody